inception was a real box-office dream
for Christopher Nolan and when the movie
was released the writer/director had
already shown that he was a master of
sequels with his baddie follow up The
Dark Knight
so it seemed entirely plausible that
Nolan would eventually go deeper into
the layers of subconscious reality with
inception to mustn't be afraid to dream
a little bigger darling
but despite an ambiguous ending and some
serious interest in a follow-up film it
just hasn't happened yet here's why
limbo inception was released right
before the Dark Knight Rises closed out
Nolan's three-part trek through Gotham
City while he wasn't traditionally a
sequel man before his Dark Knight
trilogy seemed to change us too in fact
he said that while he originally
conceived inception as a one-shot
cinematic experience he wouldn't close
the door on a possible return simply
because of the outcome of his Batman
experience
he told deadlines I've always liked the
potential of the world it's an infinite
or perhaps I should say infinitesimally
world that fascinates me
I think of Inception as one film but
that's how I approach all of my films
when I was making Batman Begins I
certainly didn't have any thoughts of
doing a second Batman film let alone a
third you never quite know where your
creative interests are going to take you
but when I was making inception I viewed
it as a standalone movie virtual reality
to further explore the dream within a
dream world he'd created Nolan
originally I'd a video game as the
preferred medium for follow-up because
it would offer an even more expansive
place for exploring all the layers of
his dream world plus let's face it some
of the movie's look just like video
games with all that minecraft style
world building and how the heroes storm
the frosty fortress like something
straight out of Goldeneye hey you know
you'd play it
the kick even if Nolan did want to
consider stepping back into the world of
inception he's kept himself pretty busy
with other projects after he returned to
Gotham for the final Dark Knight
installment after inceptions release he
ventured into all new territory with
2014's interstellar he's also written
and directed a world war 2 epic called
Dunkirk that's due in theaters in 2017
Nolan shown he has the ability to step
back into one filmmaking world after
pressing pause on it but the more movies
that stack up between inception and his
hypothetical sequel the less likely it
seems he'll ever return going graphic
the cast has been pretty swamped since
then - after Inception DiCaprio
headlined in a series of commercial and
critical successes starring in j.edgar
Django Unchained
The Great Gatsby and the wolf of
wallstreet in rapid succession then
after 5 Oscar nominations over 22 years
he won Best Actor for his leading role
in 2015's the revenant more recently
DiCaprio has turned his attention to
philanthropic filmic with documentary
before the flood and producing duties on
his upcoming big-screen Captain Planet
adaptation Tom Hardy has also starred in
a few big deal pictures you might have
heard of like The Dark Knight Rises Mad
Max fury road and the revenant and
Joseph gordon-levitt went on to make his
own directorial debut and donjon started
a bunch of hits like looper and Snowden
surely they'd all be willing to pencil
in another project with Nolan if he
asked them to but scheduling a time that
might work for all of these people could
conceivably be pretty complicated
elephant budget Saito might have had
deep enough pockets to make a second
movie happen but in the real world
budgets are a real wake-up call for
Studios looking into making a sequel
inception caused a whopping 160 million
to make and it's expected that a sequel
would have to be even bigger and better
to truly impress meaning it costs even
more in an era when sequels aren't
always a box-office guarantee that's a
risky move Warner Brothers might not be
ready to make drop the top but even with
all that in mind it's hard to shake that
spinning top and not want to see more
one of the main reasons and inception
fans have been dreaming of a sequel is
that the ending seemed to raise more
questions than it answered was Cobb
really reunited with his children at
long last in the waking world did the
spinning top that was his totem
eventually fall revealing that he'd
finally escaped the brain plane but
according to Nolan that last scene
wasn't meant to be so confusing
he told Princeton University graduates
in 2015 way the end of that film worked
Leonardo DiCaprio's character cop he was
off with his kids he was in his own
subjective reality he didn't really care
anymore and that makes a statement
perhaps all levels of reality are valid
the camera moves over the spinning top
just before it appears to be wobbling it
was cut to black you got all that your
condescension as always as much
appreciated on thank you the short
version even if you think that there is
more to tell about the final shot of
Inception Nolan doesn't thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to